yeah when welcome to this video which
covers the first round of this year's
title field tournament first of all I
have to say that this is my second take
of this video I already made one right
after the round was finished but this
fall not for unclear reasons did not
have sound this video hopefully have it
won't know what was what went wrong
there and the second thing I have to
mention is and it was important during
the event I'm going to just do them
dating round recaps but I'm not going to
do the daily Blitz videos I'm a little
bit short of time and currently am yeah
I have to focus on one thing which will
be the coverage of the tournament so
let's get going with round one ya doing
this again that's kind of funny and ok
we going to focus on not a lot going to
get all the games I just look at the
things that I feel worth watching in the
first round we had the game Wesley so
against Magnus card we can just quickly
look at this because it's the number one
seed the world champion and the second
highest seed and it was however a really
boring game everything else would be
yeah too much we have this slime so it's
line in the slaw and yeah we got lots of
trades early on and then we got this
position you have to move 15 and I don't
think I'm wrong and saying that you
don't need to be 2800 not to lose this
position it's just completely dead equal
and they haven't made a couple of moves
and then agree to draw your system not
much going on at all their game what I
want to look at a little bit at least
some critical moments is this one where
is it yes
the game between audubon and loopers
veiling re-bond is very interesting
player by the way it's not very well
known but one last year's challenger
tournament and this may qualify for this
event is a really exciting player so if
you want to watch fighting chance
audubon is one of one of the people to
watch out for and he played the c3
sicilian a bit of a surprise not exactly
an aggressive line and a LeBron is very
good at the open Sicilian so surprising
that he did not go for that again
salvini well we got fairly natural
development for both sides here with
with be six but 96 initiated some
interesting complications and we had a
situation a little bit later we haven't
really had to make a choice here this is
a very double-edged position than pawn
on d6 if yes it's a bit alone it's not
clearly supported by wise pieces but
still irritates black of course black
can or take you to Bishop takes 87
discoveries so wyd posted up the 995 and
got very active pieces yeah the critical
moment comes a little bit later we're
going to fast forward to that b3f very
active getting rid of the d4 pawn and
now taking now we see that white has two
tassels connected pesos this is a little
bit behind let's just imagine c4 c5 will
completely build those blankets that
happens the v3 porn could be dangerous
for white but it's also called the
unsupported 95 and queen deform by
audubon now initiating play against the
king and potentially make a discolored
check to win the rukon evade so can
really now have to answer a question
what to do about this threat and he has
to move that mostly came into
consideration queen should be six and
green to f6 and choosing between the two
one DZ at all he went creature of six
which proved to be a mistake Queen B 6
was better and after that white is
better but not winning and it's it's
tough to place around something like
this this looks I guess second false but
black has a counter-attack against this
so here why does a bit better but when
really certainly has good chances to
would this is what he played Queen to f6
and now this is a really interesting
situation re Barney had roughly ten
minutes and you have to make a decision
now what to do of course the right idea
the general idea is very obvious he
wants to push the pause and promote them
so the problem here is not to find your
plan the problem is too yeah how to set
this plan into motion how to actually
get it on the board he had now the
option to place before immediately
that's moving the pawns as quickly as
possible or see the position or look at
the position a little bit of a different
way check for counter play in fact
hereafter see form a black God counter
play with myself for this move looks at
g two combined power the bishop and the
night and white now have to answer
question how do you cover g2 you cannot
answer it like that Alexis looks quite
bad
well we can analyze this a little bit
but first of all I want to show you that
there is an alternative here in fact the
best move seems to be Bishop back to
everyone what is the purpose this is a
prophylactic move the bishop covers g2
so that a potential night f form is
completely losing all of its sting if
black now plays Knight f4 we can just
ignore this and play g3 ignores in the
word but there is no threat yeah the
bishop is covering all the critical
squares and black basically has to go
back and then we have to be four and so
on night again sorry Knight to f4 what's
the counter play idea it was bishop f1
that what could have been completely
killed off in fact it turns out that
after c49 fo and the game Black is okay
however the lines that are connected
with this assessment I extremely
difficult to work out during the game
and I d bar now with not much time on
the clock played Bishop c6 which is the
best move actually the interesting thing
is that the immediate porn push which is
certainly the most critical move does
not work 92 and now c6 and this looks
very obvious funny love after this black
has the book a five and wins with this
move I know it sounds crazy but this is
the only move that win for black if it
wasn't for this move white would
actually be okay crazy thing is those
kind of care complications are very
difficult to assess especially with
limited time oftentimes you can ease
your life by clicking in the good press
move a good prophylactic move like this
one yeah it's very difficult to do with
little time but this is a very nice
example after the
play with neither form is out of the
picture white almost winds automatically
here you don't have much yeah there's
not much on a chance of error yeah the
best move according to the computer is
this one but this is remove that
probably know you would play the cost
after the simple Queen trade and
something like look I'm sorry root be
one or any normal move by this is
clearly better with his tool two pawns
so that was an excellent chance 41 after
c49 f4 he played this Bishop c6 and we
got this ending now in fact he got some
chances later but at the end it dad was
a draws the big opportunity that was
missed by the by the Indian player okay
let's focus now on the main game from
round one the game between our family on
off and run Gary in Grand Master
research report report is one of the
most creative players around and he did
not disappoint him in the first round so
all looks normal and now report does not
place a standard move like Knight to f6
or something like this he goes g5 all of
a sudden pushing the Jeep on you have to
admit that I always have mixed feelings
when I see those kinds of concepts in
games on the one hand as a pure
spectator of course I like the
creativity on the other hand as a chance
teacher it always gives me some uneasy
feelings because it's in all of those
cases you know if you break rules and g5
disc brakes and rules you got to know
them first is one of the things that I
feel 11 things it's really appropriate
there are times in chess where you can
twist and twist bend the rules of the
of it but it's useful to know them first
and if you study chance and you are new
at Jeff it makes sense to play in a more
classical and more standard way and only
later try to understand when you can
bend those classical principles a little
bit better so I always feel like a hiss
stuff like that has been examples for
chest students on the objective side
this move isn't all that bad
interestingly enough we get a position
that is kind of well known but with the
pawns back here so black has invested
one temple to get this extended fear
karo instead of a standard vehicle and
it's not like g5 is weakening terminally
the way it turned out actually is here
after this reported f5 gaining lots of
space this position seems perfectly fine
for black you for b6 and I think next
position is totally okay he's gained
lots of time and there are no witnesses
really funny enough reports and had this
on the board before I have to check the
opponent against the player of
Abramovich to rated 2400 so probably in
IMO gian just roughly two and a half
years ago in this game the white player
played d5 which i think is pretty bad we
are honest and yeah after this report
got a pretty good position i think the
59 is very good and wipe some yeah whole
structure looks looks questionable and
wide can ever in such a situation
grappler exchange yes we look at this
this is extremely bad this is text
Knight f3 looks terrible so that was an
earlier games this
from report tournament practice yeah so
this was played by yanos castles 2285 so
black actually has gained lots of center
around this g5 move looked a bit yeah
the bit exotic but at the end it wasn't
healthy or the start of a center-based
healthy strategy look T 1 and now the
poor decided to change the structure in
the center he took on deform it seems
that now an alien or should have just
recaptured with the e pawn this would
have led to a very complicated position
that is not easy to assess at least for
me black should go reform and here after
Bishop f4 maybe d5 as possible let has
gained lots of ground and in the in the
process some white pieces don't actually
look all that good the bishop here feels
passive the night field Spencer on the
other hand we should never forget black
has moved tons of us pawn them and the
black team's position can feel a little
bit shaky if pieces get traded him
currently black black ski as well
shielded by pieces but if they get
traded the king could become a problem
this position is probably about equal if
the game area not plate discipline and
this truly good punish probably but in
this critical situation report does not
find the best continuation it seems that
the best movement distribution is the
move Bishop a six this is directly
looking at the Queen and initiate some
interesting complications right now
cancer editing will be exchanged
this is a very risky business if he
takes this we already see that the light
squares are very weak on the right side
and after something like this oops
what's what happened to you if it there
pawn on c4 is extremely vulnerable leg
will probably win a pawn and then has a
fantastic compensation I think here it's
just a question of how much better is
black so taking on his heaven is
extremely risky probably wise we'll just
recapture and then we get a comparable
position to the one before but I think a
little bit better in comparison before
now again and now the knight on d5 is
actually threatened after something like
90 f for like an even ignore this 96
idea about playing d5 note how active
this Bishop is only six something like
this for example black can play Bishop
takes I'll just move the Queen there's
nothing wrong with that either something
like that like that is giving blogging
absolutely tremendous compensation it's
got a pawn for the exchange a great
space advantage d 4 is weak and it's
really good it's really good for black
so that vision is six move it feels like
after that why does struggling d3r ever
was played by report and this turns out
to be probably a mistake after the
capture he played inform the idea seems
to be on what awesome idea to put the
knight on d5 and then have those jumps
but as we will see in them in the game
couple moves later if that happens it
doesn't really hurt why because what can
always sacrifice the exchange and
looking at the situation that
we had after the sacrifice we can
transfer word that you can hardly call
this a sacrifice I think almost every
decent player will just get immediately
give this exchange because the
compensation is tremendous why does got
a pawn he's got a great night on deform
and the 90 deform has yeah some nice
alternative see ya sf4 as a good square
or d5 the bishop on g2 is great and
black hands a couple of read palms and
five to six and long-term it's the king
position so here what compensation is
great in addition I mean it's
objectively very very good and in
addition it's extremely difficult to
black to play this position because it's
such an uncoordinated and coordinated
configuration that you have so we look
at this note also that black has rooks
that don't do anything there is no open
file and black has very little prospect
of opening a file and night is just a
lot stronger here a little bit later
here report try something desperate
boots with a 6 trying to play b5 but
it's just not a good position might be
six squares porn and why does not want
to trade Queens this is important with
the black king being so exposed you want
to keep keep the Queen loan unless you
win Jackie huge material but normally
the Queen should stay on yeah now
there's Luke d5 coming and after Luke t5
Ian tank report resigned yeah it's an
easy job now for white he will just
collect this and if we do account 7-port
the right had three pawns for the
exchange now and the pawns will just
easily advance in the nearest future so
a bit of a shame report some creative
opening
was not yeah was not rewarded if you
would have played Bishop a six-year that
looked very ok from like so this
somewhat yeah somewhat risky looking
opening choice um yeah turned out well
for him at first but then it it's
difficult to handle situation he didn't
it didn't do it as he didn't plate as
well as he should okay this was the
somewhat late round one coverage I hope
you enjoyed it and I'm going to do the
round to coverage shortly afterward so
those two videos will probably be
released and almost the same time thanks
for watching